oh
[Music]
introducing a brand new game in the
octopath traveler series
eight new travelers embark on a journey
through the land of celestia with that
we could realize a world without
conflict
without bloodshed
i'm going to become a star
and bring smiles to people's faces just
like mama i'm hitting the road i'll be
back once i eliminate that devil called
poverty from the world the man who took
everything from me shall die by my hand
not again not this stench the stench of
blood
doubt is what i do
leave the hunting to me we'll have all
the tasty meat you want
i need to rediscover who i am
explore a wide world set in a bustling
era
each traveler's path action differs
between day and night
our lord knows well the ways of the
world what will happen when their paths
intertwine
and what adventures await them in this
new world
the eight travelers each have their own
story to tell
where will their journeys lead them
and you
octopath traveler 2 launches on nintendo
switch february 24 2023